Добрий вечір шановні глядачі дочвелі
української перепрошую за технічні
нюанси просто нас тут виганяють суду ми
знаходимося в міжнародному суді ООН у
газі поруч зі мною Антон Кореневич Агент
України в суді посол з особливих
доручень І сьогодні ми зараз
проаналізуємо власне ситуацію з тим що ж
відбулося сьогодні яке це історичне
рішення Отже пане Антоне Скажіть будь
ласка в чому суть цього рішення в чому
його історичність І власне чого досягла
Україна рішеннями щодо цих двох
конвенцій Доброго вечора ну це перше
рішення по суті у всіх справах Україна
проти російської федерації в різних
міжнародних судах тобто Ми віримо що це
рішення стане вже воно є першим і стане
першим серед інших наступних рішень
інших міжнародних судових установ у
справах України проти російської
федерації тож початок вже є і Ми віримо
що що обов'язково буде продовження плюс
до цього це перше рішення в якому
юридичнозобов'язувальній формі
Міжнародний суд ООН встановлює що
Російська Федерація є порушником
міжнародного права тобто що Російська
Федерація порушила міжнародні договори
зокрема дві міжнародні конвенції щодо
яких Україна подавала цей позов
міжнародну конвенцію про запобігання
фінансуванню тероризму і міжнародну
конвенцію про про ліквідацію всіх форм
расової дискримінації за обома
конвенціями суд встановив що є
зобов'язання які Російська Федерація
порушила тож це для нас дуже важливо
адже ми йшли в суд саме щодо порушення
цих двох конвенції Ну і зрештою також у
цьому рішенні є два положення про
порушення Російської Федерації окремих
положень наказу про тимчасові Заходи які
суд приймав у цій справі у квітні 2017
року зокрема щодо того що Російська
Федерація порушила міжнародне право не
знявши заборону меідджлісу так яку вони
встановили і також що Російська
Федерація порушила міжнародне право
погіршивши цей спір зокрема здійснивши
так зване визнання так званої
Незалежності так званих ДНР ЛНР а також
відповідно почавши так звану спеціальну
військову операцію тож Ми віримо що це
початок Ми віримо що це початок для
впевненого руху вперед перше рішення по
суті і перше історично рішення яке
встановлює що Російська Федерація
порушник міжнародного права до цього
моменту Цього ніколи не було е так але
зрештою було багато звинувачень з боку
України на адресу Росії але було
ухвалено лише декілька з них прийнято
Тобто Чим це можна пояснити тому що
Знаєте російська пропаганда вже почала
писати що от Україна начебто там не
здобила того чого хотіла поясніть будь
ласка що саме мається на увазі саме цим
історичним рішенням Тобто ми отримали те
що не все що хотіли але подаваличи так
розумію більше звинуваченя це абсолютно
нормальна юридична тактика подавати
максимальну кількість можливих Запитів
так і можливих аргументів і
Відповідно ми це робили і робимо у
багатьох справах тому безумовно перелік
наших ймовірних порушень цих двох
конвенцій з боку Російської Федерації
був більший але для нас було важливо
отримати рішення яке фіксуватиме
порушення цих двох конвенцій з боку
Російської Федерації Тобто це було
основоположене і ми це маємо знов ж таки
е незважаючи на кількість скажімо
пунктів яких ми не бачимо у у рішенні
так фінальному Міжнародного суду вкрай
важливо до цього Російська Федерація
ніколи жодного разу в жодному рішенні
Міжнародного суду не визнавалася пору
порушувачем міжнародного права
порушником міжнародного права і ніколи
ні в яких рішеннях не фіксувалося що
вона порушила окремі статті відповідних
міжнародних договорів міжнародних
конвенцій зараз це є тож це гарний заділ
для руху вперед Дякую А які практичні
наслідки це рішення матиме тепер для
Росії ви сказали що воно визнається
фактично вперше порушником офіційно
юридично міжнародного права Які ще
наслідки Я так розумію компенсації поки
що про це мова не йде про репарації це
буде інша справа у цьому рішенні цього
зараз немає Так але зафіксовано що перше
що Російська Федерація порушує
Міжнародне право як ви знаєте У нас є
наступна справа в цьому суді друга
справа про звинувачення у геноциді яку
ми будемо слухати по рішення щодо щодо
наявності у суду юрисдикцію вже в цю
п'ятницю і Відповідно ми сподіваємося
також що рішення суду буде таке що суд
має юрисдикцію в цій справі є справи
України проти Росії в інших судах це
Європейський суд прав людини у
страсбурзі це міжнародні
трибунали по конвенції з морського права
анклоз Тобто це рішення Я впевнений буде
важливим для ходу справ Україна проти
Росії в усіх інших юрисдикціях я нагадаю
нашим глядачам які щойно приєдналися
Мене звати Максим драбок це дочвелі ми
знаходимося у міжнародно
судді в газі Перепрошую що технічно воно
виглядає Саме так бо вдалося
поспілкуватися пан Антон Кореневич посол
з надзвичайних з особливих дорученнь МЗС
України і Агент України тут судді
знайшов декілька хвилин щоб
поспілкуватися Мені буквально вдалося
його зловити тут в коридорах в кулуарах
суду тому Перепрошую що технічно можливо
воно виглядає на ідеально Але тим не
менше він нам говорить ексклюзивну
інформацію про наслідки сьогоднішнього
історичного рішення а саме рішення по
суті щодо справи Україна проти Росії цей
процес тривав с років нагадаю Отже
Скажіть будь ласка як це Рішення ще ВНО
на інші суди Я так розумію що тут ще
декілька с справ розглядається в
міжнародному судді ООН які це справи Ну
по-перша це справа про Україна проти
російської федерації щодо звинувачення у
геноциді і вже у цю п'ятницю 2 лютого
цей суд офіційно винесе рішення щодо
того чи має він юрисдикцію слухати цю
справу по суті тож це теж дуже важливий
момент для для того щоб розуміти чи буде
та справа рухатися тут в судді далі
окрім того у нас є справи в
Європейському суді зправ людини
міждержавні Україна проти російської
федерації так як я вже зазначав цей
трибунал із морського права тобто
безумовно на рішення міжнародного судун
звертають увагу всі інші юрисдикції так
і всі умовно аналізують те що які
рішення прийняв І що зрештою в тому чи
іншому питанні сказав міжнародний судон
як головний судовий орган Організації
Об'єднаних Націй Тож ми переко що це
рішення знову ж таки буде оцим першим
рішенням у справах по суті і в
майбутньому ми обов'язково будемо мати
більше таких рішень з різних міжнародних
судів якщо ще перекласти так би мовити з
юридичної мови на людську от оце рішення
щодо конвенції щодо тероризму тобто
фактично суд визнав що Росія не докдала
не
докладала зусиль щодо моніторингу
фінансової діяльності тобто фінансування
тероризму але при цьому як стверджують
деякі аналі політики міжнародники що за
класичним трактуванням конвенції пішла
тобто постачання військової зброї
зокрема бука так воно не було прийнято
до до уваги чи як це правильно пояснити
в цілому так в цілому так тобто
міжнародний судон визнав що Російська
Федерація порушила міжнародну конвенцію
про запобігання фінансування тероризму В
тому що вона не здійснювала належних
розслідувань фактів імовірного вчинення
злочину фінансування тероризму на
територіях східної України Так про які
Україна повідомляла росій ї Федерації
відпоідно реакції ніякої не було це
порушення статті дев'ять пункт оди цієї
конвенції Ну і так Україна заявляла і в
нас була позиція щодо того що відповідно
постачання озброєнь також і бук згаданий
вами так який застосовувався для збиття
рейсу 17 інше озброєння що це теж
підпадає під визначення фанс яке
міститься в Конвенції бо воно широке ну
бачимо що міжнародний судон прийняв таке
рішення Але знову ж таки повторюся і
повторю те що сказав на початку що для
нас дуже важливо що міжнарод судон
визнав російську федерацію порушником
міжнародного права дякую вам дуже отже
Це був Антон
Кореневич посол з особливих доручень МЗС
України і Агент України тут у судді
міжнародному судді ООН у газі Він саме
Він
представляє серед інших команду
українських юристів міжнародників Отже
сьогодні нагадаю нашим глядачам Що
відбулося історичне засідання через с
років судового процесу міжнародни суд он
виніс рішення щодо е двох конвенцій а
саме справа України проти Росії щодо
тероризму та запобігання расової
дискримінації це тобто Крим і Донбас -
це період
2014-15 роки е також е як сказав пан
Антон що головне історичне рішення - це
те що Україна хоче частково але є
визнана порушником міжнародного права і
це вже зафіксовано юридично